deep beneath the earth in Chihuahua
Mexico grows a real world Fortress of
Solitude in 1910 in the neck of mine in
Mexico the bernoulli's mining company
discovered what came to be known as the
cave of swords it was an 80 meter long
hallway with beautiful gypsum crystals
growing up to 2 meters in length
unfortunately the cave was opened up for
exploration and later tourism which
destroyed many of the crystals 90 years
later two miners working for the same
company stumbled on another cave except
this one was much much bigger naica sits
on an ancient fault line above a magma
chamber this heated the groundwater and
filled it with sulfide ions so when this
hot sulfide brew met with the cool
oxygenated water in the cave they didn't
mix exactly they kind of sat on top of
each other but the oxygen began to
diffuse into this rich sulfide soup and
slowly an infinitesimal pace these
crystals began to form they've been
growing for half a million years today
the largest crystal in the cave is 12
meters in length four meters in diameter
and 55 tons it is 20 times bigger than
any previously known crystal amazingly
there's there's no limit to how big
these crystals can get given enough time
they will grow ever larger these are
fortress of solitude crystals they are
Superman crystals one big difference
between the fortress of solitude and the
cave of crystals is the temperature the
cave of crystals is blisteringly hot it
is 50 degrees Celsius or 122 Fahrenheit
and the humidity level is a constant 90%
even wearing special cooling suits
filled with ice and water researchers
were only able to spend about 40 minutes
down there these crystals grew
underwater it's only in the last 20
years this mining company has pumped out
all of the groundwater so they can
extract various precious ores from the
area but as soon as it doesn't make
economic sense for this mining company
the crystals will be
Riis submerge returned to their
underwater existence and this is
probably for the best because well it's
incredible we get the chance to study
them now that's their natural
environment it's where they grew it's
where they can keep growing and I think
considering how beautiful but also how
fragile these are just knowing that
they're under your feet growing ever
larger is more than enough subscribe
here and watch more videos here
this isn't gypsum this is salt the Nyko
project is doing a ton of amazing
science around this including looking at
ancient life forms in these crystals and
trying to find their closest relative
I've included a link down below if
you're interested in learning more about
that